my name is alan taylor
and i'm professor of seed science and
technology at cornell agritech
my laboratory has been involved in hemp
seed science and technology research
since the cornell hemp team
formed in 2017. what i'm going to speak
about
today is on our work on the research and
development of hemp seed treatments
gary bergstrom is my cooperator in plant
pathology as his laboratory
is supportive and helping characterize
the pathogens associated with
disease seedlings from our research
plots
we also have phil trials at north dakota
state with burton johnson
and chuck johnson and john fike at
virginia tech
so the focus of our work is on
application technology to begin
with to have good methodology
for seed treatment and coding
technologies this is a laboratory scale
unit called a rotary pan technology an
r6 for a six inch diameter
the same technology is used for
commercial scale equipment
so anything that we do in the laboratory
can quickly be scaled up to a larger
an issue that we had early on is that we
need to ensure that we have a uniformity
of application
over the seed surface and from seed to
seed
we need to protect each seed from attack
of the soil borne pathogens at time of
sowing
we'll take a step back and look at the
biological market as there's a number of
materials
now this is not restricted to seed
treatments these could be
foliar applications or soil applications
and furrow
applications we have bio fertilizers and
biostimulants which we're not going to
be talking about
even though my laboratory is working
with biostimulant seed treatments but
we're going to focus on biological
control products
in particular the bio pesticide so we're
going to kind of focus in on that area
so under the bio pesticides we have
biochemicals
they may be kind of a mineral based they
can be either formed from
copper or phosphites we have examples of
those
microbials we normally think of a
microbial as a bio-pesticide
but they're not the only materials but
in this case we are using specific seed
treatments of
from bacillus and trichoderma and with
others
and these are commercial formulations
that we are
testing on as seed treatments
so this is our list of 12 seed
treatments that we have those in green
are the biologicals
first thing we have to do is test the
seed treatment
application rate we want to ensure that
there's no phytotoxicity
from the seed treatments those in red
are the biochemicals
safeguard is an organic copper the
protein is a phosphite material
and then the group at the bottom in blue
apron xl maxim you probably recognize
as these are widely labeled on
vegetables
and field crops for as seed treatments
so first let's look at what happens
to seeds after they're planted we start
off here in the laboratory to look at
hemp seeds germinate very rapidly so in
this pathogen
infested soil that we have the soil
sprinkled over on top during the
germination process
after four days the seeds germinate very
rapidly
after seven days many of the seedlings
have died or are dying
and by 10 days non-treated seeds
are killed so this is a way that we can
use
a laboratory screening method you taking
advantage of a naturally pathogenic
pathogen-infested soil to go ahead and
to test these
seed treatments before we actually go to
the field
but our primary interest in showing you
today
is the field data this is our two we
have two stick
field studies at cornell the first one
planted in june 12.
again now we can see how this color
coding is going to help us the black bar
on the left is the control non-treated
you see all the grain treatments none of
the biological is doing any better than
the control
however the safeguard the organic copper
the the prudent the phosphate doing
quite well and as good
as one of our best apron maxim
treatments
so this looks very promising we have a
second study
also in ithaca this year planted on june
26th
again the same trend is the biologicals
not performing any better than the
non-treated control
we are seeing improvements with both the
safeguard
in particular the safeguard and the
prudent and again it's comparable to
our best apron maxim treatment as the
chemical seed treatment
this is where gary's laboratory was was
instrumental in supporting this project
we would see the symptoms in the field
as far as disease seedlings
his laboratory has done the
characterization
of what pathogens are associated with
those disease seedlings so we can see
here
in the picture on the the photo at the
bottom on the left
indicative of those testing positive for
fusarium species
they picture on the lower right having
pythium species present
gary's laboratory is still ongoing work
to characterize the species
of these along with other samples that
we have provided
to their lab as i said this is a
multi-state project
and being a multi-state project is good
in that we do not want to simply have
seeds that are tested in cornell that
only have
good control in the northeast so we've
expanded the testing we have
seed testing at virginia tech in the
southern region
and then north dakota state and the
north central region
again the same color coding in the same
scheme
as we had in our previous slides we see
safeguard
and prudent doing very well and this is
from one study we have there'll be one
more study coming
with data this fall from virginia tech
and then north dakota state in this case
we're seeing the chemical seed
treatments
doing quite well uh in this one across
the board
but still we're seeing for example
safeguard doing a nice job
so we're gathering information now and
the very
good picture is that they were seeing
some consistency
in our results from field to field
and from location to location
within the regions of the united states
so let's go ahead and summarize where
we're at with this
our biochemical seed treatments the
safeguard which was the organic copper
and the prudent which is a phosphite had
good efficacy
in all the studies the data that we have
in hand at this
point in time the chemical seed
treatments apron xl and maxim
still had good efficacy and again these
are tried and true
chemical seed treatments that are widely
labeled
unfortunately after two years of work
where syngenta
was initially very interested in this
project
syngenta is no longer providing support
for hemp
on any particular application so it
could be syngenta herbicides
and things like that they're not going
to be supporting those hemp labels in
the united states which is
is a big setback so we really need other
chemical seed treatments from another
company to test and we're looking into
that at this time
finally the biologicals and we've done
now two years in a row trying to test
a good range of commercially available
and use biological seed treatments
simply were not
effective in our study to control
damping off
so i want to thank people first of all
in my laboratory
hillary mayton hillary kind of
headed up all the field studies that you
had as well as gathering data
from the other states
and then summarizing some of the data in
the graphs that you're seeing
michael lewis in my laboratory has done
all the seed
treatment application a lot of the
in-house testing as far as germination
soil testing and i saw bioassay
massey's done a lot of the photographic
work and other support work for this
project so
very nice team i'm very fortunate to
have people
working with me on this project in
gary's laboratory
jen starr was really instrumental in
working
with hillary taking those field samples
and doing the characterization
and kevin and gary's lab is helping at
the molecular characterization
so we know what species are involved
again we work very closely with the
company registrants in other words the
companies that actually
are producing these we're working
directly with our r
d people to make sure that we're testing
the best
biological chemical biochemical
treatment that they would have available
for this project and finally i want to
thank
support from ir4 but in particular for
new york ag and markets for their
continued support
for this and for other cornell hemp
projects
thank you very much